♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HAPPY WEDNESDAY.
WELL, IT LOOKS LIKE THIS IS THE
PART OF THE REVOLUTION WHERE
THEY START THROWING THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS IN JAIL.
THAT WAS FAST.
IT WAS JUST A WEEK AGO THEY WERE
TELLING US ABOUT UNITY.
REMEMBER THAT?
WELL, WE DIDN’T KNOW AT THE TIME
THAT EVERYONE WITH POWER SHOULD
UNITE AGAINST THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
UNITY MEANT OLIGARCHY.
OH, DOUG MACKEY LEARNED THAT THE
HARD WAY THIS MORNING.
HE IS A 31-YEAR-OLD CONSERVATIVE
JOURNALIST FROM FLORIDA.
AT 7:00 A.M., FBI AGENTS SHOWED
UP AT HIS HOUSE COME UP THROUGH
HIM IN HANDCUFFS AND INTO A
CELL.
HE NOW FACES 10 YEARS IN PRISON.
HIS CRIME?
HE MADE POWER DON’T MAKE FUN OF
POWERFUL DEMOCRATS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
"HE MADE A COORDINATED USE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA TO SPREAD
DISINFORMATION RELATIVE TO THE
2016 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THIS DISINFORMATION "OFTEN TOOK
THE FORM OF MEMES.
YES, ONLINE MOCKERY.
IT IS NOW ILLEGAL WHEN IT’S
AIMED AT THE WRONG PEOPLE.
DOUG MACKEY HURT THEIR FEELINGS
SO THEY PUT THEM IN PRISON.
HE VIOLATED 18 SECTION 241.
HE DID THIS BY TRICKING PEOPLE
LIKE THE TRICKSTER HE IS INTO
NOT VOTING IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
WHAT IS INTERESTING IS THE
PROSECUTORS SHOWED NO EVIDENCE
WHATSOEVER THAT DOUG MACKEY
ACTUALLY TRICKED ANYONE INTO ANY
THING VOTING OR NOT, NOT A
SINGLE PERSON.
BUT THAT DOESN’T MATTER SHRIEKED
TO CNN.
DOUG MACKEY IS A BAD PERSON WITH
BAD VIEWS.
AND BY THE WAY, WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT HIS VIEWS ARE.
WE DON’T CARE.
WHAT CNN IS TELLING US IS THAT
THOSE VIEWS ARE A CRIME.
HE’S A CRIMINAL.
LOCK HIM UP.
GIVEN A LONGER SENTENCE THAN WE
GIVE HIM TO.
HOLD ON A MINUTE AS A LEGAL
MATTER.
HAVE YOU EVER READ SECTION 241?
PROBABLY NOT, BUT YOU SHOULD.
WHEN YOU READ IT, YOU WILL LEARN
THAT JOE BIDEN’S JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS LYING IN AN
OBVIOUS WAY AND THAT SHOULD MAKE
YOU NERVOUS.
IT TURNS OUT THAT FEDERAL LAW
DOES NOT BAN MEMES OR FOR THAT
MATTER MISINFORMATION, THE LAW
THAT THEY ARE CITING AND INSTEAD
PROHIBITS "CONSPIRING TO INJURE,
OPPRESS, THREATEN, OR
INTIMIDATING ANYONE FROM
EXERCISING THE RIGHT TO VOTE."
ACCORDING TO LAW, THAT WOULD
INCLUDE KIDNAPPING VOTERS,
INVADING THEIR HOMES, SEXUALLY
ABUSING THEM.
HE DIDN’T DO ANYTHING LIKE THAT
ANYTHING CLOSE TO THAT.
HE MADE MEMES.
SPEECH IS VIOLENT.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE
FIRST AMENDMENT?
WELL, IT MEANS THAT IT IS
EFFECTIVELY SUSPENDED.
YOU CAN NOW BE ARRESTED FOR
SAYING THE WRONG THING AT AT
7:00 P.M., ONE JOURNALIST WAS
ACTUALLY ARRESTED FOR THAT.
NO ONE IS DEFENDING HIM.
HE HAD BAD THOUGHTS.
HE DESERVED IT.
THEY THINK IT IS OKAY.
THAT SHOULDN’T SURPRISE YOU
BECAUSE WE ARE CLEARLY LIVING
UNDER SOME FORM OF MARTIAL LAW
AT THE MOMENT.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT?
WELL, HERE IS ONE.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY 10,000
TROOPS IN OUR CAPITAL CITY
TONIGHT.
HOW LONG WILL THEY BE STAYING?
NO ONE IS SPECIFIC ABOUT ANY OF
THAT SO YOU ARE LEFT TO DRAW
YOUR OWN CONCLUSIONS WHICH
PEOPLE NATURALLY ARE.
BY THE WAY, IT’S NOT MAKING
ANYONE MORE MODERATE.
IF YOU ARE REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
EXTREMISM, YOU PROBABLY WANT TO
PUT 10,000 TROOPS IN YOUR
CAPITAL CITY MAKING EVERYONE
MORE RADICAL AND CRAZY.
BUT THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THAT.
THE POINT OF THIS WHOLE
HIGHLY-MILITARIZED EXERCISE IT
TOISTO REMIND YOU OF WHAT --
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS TRUE.
IN EVERY COUNTRY AT ALL TIMES.
CHRIS MURPHY IS NO GENIUS BUT HE
DOES UNDERSTAND THAT.
AS HE EXPLAINED TODAY, AS LONG
AS HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS
EXIST, THOUGH SOLDIERS WILL
STAY.
>> THE THREAT TO THE COUNTRY IS
NOT OVER, RIGHT?
WE STILL HAVE 5,000
NATIONAL GUARD MEMBERS
SURROUNDING THE CAPITOL COMPLEX.
WHY?
BECAUSE THERE ARE STILL EXISTING
THREATS, PRESENT THREATS TO THE
SECURITY OF THE CAPITAL.
AND SO, SO LONG AS DONALD TRUMP
IS EMPOWERED BY SENATE
REPUBLICANS, THERE IS STILL THE
CHANCE THAT HE IS GOING TO
INCITE ANOTHER ATTEMPT AT THE
CAPITAL.
THE THREAT IS STILL VERY REAL TO
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO AS LONG AS THERE ARE PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY WHO PERSIST IN
DISAGREEING WITH CHRIS MURPHY,
WE ARE GOING TO NEED TO KEEP
HEAVILY ARMED SOLDIERS ON THE
SCENE.
WHY QUESTION MIKE AND WE ARE
QUOTING NOW.
"THE THREAT IS STILL VERY REAL
TO AMERICAN DEMOCRACY."
BUT WAIT, DEMOCRACY REQUIRES
SOLDIERS?
WE THOUGHT IT WAS VOLUNTARY.
IF YOU ARE STARTING TO THINK
THAT MAYBE SOMEONE SECRETLY
REDEFINED THE TERM DEMOCRACY,
CHANGING ITS MEANING TO ROUGHLY
180 DEGREES FROM WHAT IT WAS
JUST LAST YEAR, YOU MAY BE ONTO
SOMETHING.
WHAT WE ARE LOOKING AT NOW IS
NOT DEMOCRACY IN THE CLASSICAL
ATHENIAN SCIENCE WHERE EVERYONE
GETS TO VOTE AND THE VOICE OF
EVERYONE MATTERS EQUALLY, NO, WE
ARE LOOKING AT NOW DEMOCRACY IN
THE 1970s EASTERN BLOC
PEOPLE’S DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC.
THIS NEW VERSION OF DEMOCRACY IS
WHERE EVERYONE AGREES WITH THE
PEOPLE IN POWER OR ELSE THEY GO
IMMEDIATELY TO JAIL.
HIS PROBLEM IS THAT HE DIDN’T
PROPERLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
DEMOCRACY IS.
THANKFULLY, CONGRESSMAN TIM RYAN
OF OHIO DOES UNDERSTAND IT AND
HE EXPLAINED IT TO US TODAY.
WE ARE NOT LETTING THOUGH
SOLDIERS GO HOME, TIM RYAN SAID,
AND UNTIL THEY DO WHAT OUR SPECI
OPERATIONS FORCES DID IN IRAQ
AND AFGHANISTAN.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHO IN OUR GOVERNMENT, IN OUR
MILITARY HAS HAD EXPERIENCE
AROUND CROWD CONTROL?
MAYBE SPECIAL OPERATION FORCES
IN IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN.
LIKE, HOW CAN WE LEARN
EVERYTHING WE NEED TO LEARN TO
RESET THE POSTURE ON
CAPITOL HILL ESTHER MARK AND WE
ARE NOT GOING TO LET THE
NATIONAL GUARD GO HOME.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO CREATE AN
UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT UNTIL WE HAVE
THAT FIGURED OUT.
THE ONE OH OH ARE SPECIALISTS IN
CONTROLLING UNRULY POPULATIONS.
WE GET IT.
RATHER THAN ANSWER OUR QUESTIONS
OR IMPROVE OUR LIVES, YOU ARE
BRINGING IN PEOPLE WITH GUNS TO
REMIND US THAT YOU ARE IN
CHARGE.
THAT’S A BIG CHANGE.
YOU MAY HAVE THOUGHT YOU WERE A
DECENT AMERICAN IN GOOD
STANDINGS.
THEY WEREN’T EXTREME THEN.
YOU DON’T THINK YOU ARE
CONSTRAINED NOW.
YOU’VE ALWAYS CONSIDERED
YOURSELF A PRETTY MODERATE
PERSON.
LIVE YOUR LIFE AND GET ALONG
WITH OTHERS.
THAT’S NOT POSSIBLE NOW BECAUSE
THE RULES HAVE CHANGED.
YOU ARE NOW A DANGEROUS
INSURGENT.
YOU ARE NO DIFFERENT FROM A
BLOODTHIRSTY OR AN ISIS
TERRORIST.
YOU ARE PART OF A GUERRILLA
INSURGENCY OR MAYBE IT’S A
GORILLIA.
SOME OF THOSE LEADERS SEEM
SUSPICIOUSLY FURRY.
HERE IS THE MASTERMIND.
THE JIHADI KNOWN BY THE
CHEWBACCA GUY.
>> HEY!
[BLEEP] HEY MAN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU GUYS.
LOOK AT THIS GUY.
>> DO YOU NEED MEDICAL
ATTENTION?
YOU GOOD SIR?
>> I GOT SHOT IN THE FACE WITH
SOME KIND OF PLASTIC BULLET.
I AM DISRESPECTING THE PLACE.
>> Tucker: SAD NEWS TONIGHT.
CHEWBACCA GUY IS NO LONGER
AVAILABLE FOR YOUR KID’S SEVENTH
BIRTHDAY PARTY.
HE’S IN PRISON TONIGHT.
WHEN THEY DO, SANDY CORTEZ WILL
BREATHE EASIER.
BACK DURING THE GREAT TERRORIST
SIEGE OF JANUARY, SHE FOUND
HERSELF IN THE SAME CITY AS
CHEWBACCA GUY APPEAR LITERALLY
IN THE SAME CITY TRAPPED AND
ABANDONED JUST LIKE
THOSE LONELY VALIANT TROOPS SO
MANY YEARS AGO.
SHE REALLY THOUGHT SHE WAS GOING
TO DIE.
>> I HAD A PRETTY TRAUMATIZING
EVENT HAPPEN TO ME.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT I HAD A VERY
CLOSE ENCOUNTER WHERE I THOUGHT
I WAS GOING TO DIE.
>> Tucker: SO THANKFULLY THEY
HAVE ARRESTED CHEWBACCA GUY AND
ARRESTED HIS BAND OF TERRORISTS
OVER 65 YEARS OLD.
SO THERE IS STILL A LITTLE
JUSTICE IN THIS COUNTRY.
BUT THEY ARE NOT THE ONLY THREAT
THAT HE FACES TONIGHT.
FAR FROM IT.
THEY ARE THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
SOME OF THEM ARE REPUBLICANS AND
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
AT ANY MOMENT, THESE PEOPLE ARE
LIKELY TO OPEN FIRE
INDISCRIMINATELY ON THE HOUSE
FLOOR PURELY OUT OF RACISM AND
SHE’S WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
LISTEN.
>> WE STILL DON’T FEEL SAFE
AROUND OTHER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
>> HOW MANY ARE WE?
>> I THINK A VERY CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT.
THE MOMENT YOU BRING A GUN ONTO
THE HOUSE FLOOR IN VIOLATION OF
RULES, YOU PUT EVERYONE AROUND
YOU IN DANGER.
I DON’T CARE IF YOU ACCIDENTALLY
SET IT OFF.
I DON’T CARE IF YOU
INTENTIONALLY SET IT OFF.
I DON’T CARE IF YOU DON’T SET IT
OFF AT ALL, YOU ARE ENDANGERING
THE LIVES OF MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS
THAT WE EVEN HAVE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION.
>> Tucker: IT’S OUTRAGEOUS.
ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS SAID THE
LEADER OF AMERICA’S NARCISSISM
PARTY, THE FASTEST GROWING PARTY
IN THE COUNTRY.
EVEN ON THE HOUSE FLOOR
SURROUNDED BY OTHER ELECTED
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED, SANDY
CORTEZ DOES NOT FEEL SAFE.
THAT IS WHY WE NEED TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF TROOPS OUTSIDE HER
OFFICE TONIGHT SO THAT SHE CAN
FINALLY FOR ONCE TAKE A BREATH
AND GET BACK TO THE BUSINESS OF
MAKING PERKY INSTAGRAM VIDEOS
ABOUT HERSELF.
THE BUSINESS OF THE PEOPLE, IT
MUST GO ON.
OF COURSE IT MUST.
APPEAR WE ALL
SUPPORT THAT.
TALKING ABOUT THE PEOPLE, YOU
GOT TO WONDER WHAT THEY THINK
ABOUT ALL OF THIS, THE ACTUAL
PEOPLE.
NONE OF THIS IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ACTUALLY SUFFERING IN
OUR COUNTRY, THE MILLIONS OF
THEM.
NO.
WE ARE WATCHING ONE OF THOSE
RARE REVOLUTIONS, RARE IN WORLD
HISTORY THAT IS BEING WAGED NOT
ON BEHALF OF THE POPULATION, BUT
AGAINST THIS.
ALL OF THIS IS BEING DONE
EXPRESSLY FOR THE OLIGARCHS.
NONE OF IT IS BEING DONE FOR
YOU.
OF COURSE IF YOU LIVE IN
WASHINGTON TO SEE, YOU ALREADY
LIVE VERY WELL.
FEDERAL TROOPS ARE NOT
PROTECTING YOUR HOME TONIGHT.
SANDY CORTEZ DOESN’T CARE IF YOU
GET ROBBED OR CARJACKED AS MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE ARE AS PRIME
SKYROCKETED.
SANDY CORTEZ AND HER FRIENDS
WANT TO ABOLISH YOUR POLICE, NOT
THEIR POLICE.
HERE IS A SCENE FROM THE REST OF
THE CITY OF WASHINGTON.
>> DUNCAN WAS 15 MONTHS OLD WHEN
HE WAS FATALLY SHOT WEDNESDAY
NIGHT IN SOUTHEAST.
HIS FATHER WAS DRIVING THE
VEHICLE AND THE TODDLER WAS
STRAPPED INTO HIS CAR SEAT WHEN
HE WAS STRUCK WITH BULLETS.
A PRELIMINARY INVESTIGATION
POINTED OUT AT LEAST TWO PEOPLE
OPEN FIRE ON THE CAR AS HE DROVE
BY.
>> Tucker: THE TODDLER WAS
STRUCK WITH BULLETS IN HIS CAR
SEAT RIGHT NEXT TO HIS FATHER.
THIS HAPPENED IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE OF THE CAPITAL.
BUT NO ONE INSIDE THAT DOME
BUILDING, THE ONES YOU ARE SO
AFRAID OF CHEWBACCA MAN, NOTICED
OR CARED.
SO WHATEVER ELSE YOU CONCLUDE
FROM THIS, THIS TALE OF TWO
COCITIES, TO DIP INTO A CLICHE,
HERE IS ONE THING YOU CAN BE
CERTAIN OF.
IT’S NOT ACTUALLY VIOLENCE THAT
SANDY CORTEZ AND HER FELLOW